Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。挑战中还有由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. So episode 72, can't quite believe it, but thank you so much, especially if you followed me right from the beginning your enthusiasm and knowing how much you value this is so appreciated and keeps me going please do take a moment to rate and review the podcast on spotify and on apple and if you are willing to leave me an audio testimonial or even just to drop into my DMs with a testimonial about why you like the podcast so much, I would be thrilled to receive it. I personally love learning about new ways to conduct therapy and to deliver therapy as well. And today's podcast is no exception to that. I'm going to be chatting with Dr. Abby
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。这是第72期节目，真不敢相信，非常感谢大家，特别是那些从一开始就关注我的人，你们的热情以及对本节目的重视让我深受鼓舞，也让我坚持了下去。请花点时间在Spotify和Apple上为播客评分和评论。如果你愿意留下音频感言，或者只是在私信中告诉我你为什么这么喜欢这个播客，我会非常高兴。我个人非常喜欢学习进行治疗和提供治疗的新方法，今天的播客也不例外。我将与艾比（Abby）交谈，
Tarrant-Jones who is the outdoor psychologist and we're thinking about practical ways to take what we do in the therapy room outside the traditional four walls of a therapy room. I hope you'll find it so useful, so interesting. Abby was a delight to speak to and I will catch up with you on the other side. Welcome along. I just want to welcome my guest for today, Dr. Abby Tarrant-Jones. Abby is a clinical psychologist and is the outdoor psychologist. Hi, Abby. Hi, Marianne. Thank you so much for coming on um i've been following you on linkedin i often talk about linkedin on here and it's how i get my guests i love linkedin
她是塔兰特-琼斯（Tarrant-Jones）博士，也是一位“户外心理学家”。我们正在思考如何将治疗室里的工作带到传统四壁之外的实际方法。希望你会觉得这期节目既实用又有趣。与艾比交谈非常愉快，稍后我会回来。欢迎来到节目。我想欢迎今天的嘉宾，艾比·塔兰特-琼斯博士。艾比是一位临床心理学家，也是一位户外心理学家。你好，艾比。你好，玛丽安。非常感谢你来到这里，我一直在领英（LinkedIn）上关注你，我经常在这里提到领英，这也是我寻找嘉宾的方式，我喜欢领英，
and i love when i see people that are doing psychology but doing it a little bit differently so that is absolutely how you caught my interest yeah Yeah thanks Marianne. I think I haven't always practiced differently so I am now working in an independent practice after kind of taking a big leap out of the NHS in order to kind of proactively innovate the way that I work. So as the title suggests I take therapy into nature and the outdoors and I'm really excited to talk to you about that today. And I know that I'm excited to learn but our audience will be really excited to hear and think about perhaps how they might be able to to start doing some of this as well. So I know before we went on camera we were saying that actually not everybody gets it do they not everyone thinks it's like an evidence-based thing
我也喜欢看到那些从事心理学工作但方式略有不同的人，这就是你吸引我的原因。是的，谢谢你，玛丽安。我想我并不总是以不同的方式执业，我现在是在一家独立诊所工作，在离开英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）迈出这一大步之后，为了主动创新我的工作方式。正如标题所示，我将治疗带入自然和户外，今天我非常高兴能与你讨论这个问题。我知道我很兴奋能学习，但我们的听众也会非常兴奋地听到并思考他们或许可以如何开始做其中的一些事情。我知道在录制前我们说过，并不是每个人都理解这一点，对吧？并不是每个人都认为这是一种循证疗法，
or it's something we even should be doing or whether we should be funding it is that something you're coming up against quite a lot Abby? I think that traditionally therapy has always been considered that it takes place in the four walls of the clinic room. And that's kind of how it's been delivered since kind of Freud brought up the idea of psychoanalysis. and a lot of the time we end up delivering treatments and therapies within organizations, within kind of standardized protocols and guidance in order to ensure that, I guess, the treatments we're delivering are effective and evidence-based and safe, etc. And the majority of the research that's been undertaken into talking therapies has been delivered in this traditional way. So I think what's fair to say is that the evidence-based
或者认为这是我们应该做的事情，又或者是否应该为此提供资金。艾比，这是你经常遇到的问题吗？我认为传统上，治疗一直被认为是在诊室的四壁之内进行的。自弗洛伊德提出精神分析的概念以来，它一直是以这种方式提供的。很多时候，我们最终是在组织内部、在标准化的协议和指导方针下提供治疗和疗法，以确保我们提供的治疗是有效、循证且安全的等等。而针对谈话疗法进行的大多数研究都是以这种传统方式进行的。所以我想说的是，户外谈话疗法的循证基础
for outdoor talking therapy is developing. Sam Cooley has done a lot of research into the outdoor talking therapy is developing. Sam Cooley has done a lot of research into the outdoor talking therapy and developed together with Noel the BPS guidance for taking therapy outdoors which was published in 2020 pretty much on the back of or as a result of how practice was having to change because of COVID that suddenly we were thrust into this situation where we couldn't deliver therapy in the typical way so it was either we go remote and you know what what we recognized I was working at the time in the NHS in an older adult setting and there was many people who didn't have access to the technology didn't have the skills to access the technology and we were having to find more innovative ways
正在发展中。萨姆·库利（Sam Cooley）对户外谈话疗法做了大量研究，并与诺埃尔（Noel）一起制定了英国心理学会（BPS）关于户外治疗的指导方针，该指南于2020年发布，几乎是在新冠疫情导致实践必须改变的背景下或结果下产生的。突然之间，我们陷入了无法以典型方式提供治疗的境地，所以要么我们转向远程，你知道，我们当时意识到，我当时在NHS的老年人部门工作，许多人无法使用技术，也没有技能去获取技术，我们必须找到更具创新性的方法
of providing therapeutic support to our clients so I think the majority of the world went remote. And what I loved was that Cooley really jumped on an opportunity to explore the power of outdoor torturing therapy and to invest some time in metasynthesizing the evidence base for that. so I guess I use a lot of the information that they developed through that guidance to inform my work and make sure that the therapy that I'm delivering is evidence-based and effective and I can talk more to a theme some of that evidence-based about our conversation today brilliant thank you yeah and I guess the guidance was already perhaps on its way but then the pandemic came around and it was like more relevant than ever yeah exactly I think um like we saw with COVID in many kind of organizational settings with unprecedented change came unprecedented opportunity for innovation um and it's wonderful in some ways that some clinicians and therapists started to kind of adapt the way they were working in some ways what
来为我们的客户提供治疗支持，所以我认为世界上大多数人都转向了远程。我喜欢的是，库利确实抓住了探索户外谈话疗法力量的机会，并投入了一些时间来对循证基础进行元综合。所以我猜我利用了他们通过该指南开发的大量信息来指导我的工作，并确保我提供的治疗是循证且有效的，我可以在今天的谈话中更多地谈论其中的一些循证基础。太棒了，谢谢。是的，我想指导方针可能已经在制定中了，但后来疫情来了，它变得比以往任何时候都更相关。是的，完全正确。我想，正如我们在新冠疫情中在许多组织环境中看到的那样，前所未有的变化带来了前所未有的创新机会。
I think could be a bit of a shame is that as the restrictions around COVID have been removed there's a sense, do we go back to working as usual, or do we stay online? And I feel like there's a possibility that organisations can really, are really missing the boat here on embracing a truly kind of holistic and creative opportunity to engage with our clients and enable them to, I guess, have a more empowered position within their therapeutic and recovery journeys. Yeah, I think there's and there's real power to human connection, isn't there? And of course, the internet is really useful. But I personally haven't been in a therapy room with a client since the beginning of March 2020. So that is over three years now, which is strange, isn't it? Because I obviously learned my craft, as you will
在某些方面，一些临床医生和治疗师开始调整他们的工作方式，这真是太棒了。我认为有点遗憾的是，随着新冠疫情限制的解除，人们有一种感觉：我们是回到正常工作状态，还是保持在线？我觉得组织有可能真的错失了拥抱一种真正全面和创造性的机会，来与我们的客户互动，并使他们能够在治疗和康复之旅中处于更有权力的地位。是的，我认为人与人之间的联系确实有真正的力量，对吧？当然，互联网非常有用。但我个人自2020年3月初以来就没有和客户在治疗室里待过了。所以那已经是三年多了，这很奇怪，不是吗？因为我显然是在学习我的手艺，就像你一样，
have done, in person with people. And it's a very different craft indeed, isn't it? I obviously learned my craft as you will have done in person with people and it's a very different craft indeed isn't it even with us you know navigating connection speeds and things this morning and you know yeah in the beginning trying to sort out your audio and you know it's a different beast entirely I think it is um it's uh I guess I it sits uncomfortably with me in some ways i wouldn't be able to practice remotely um in its entirety like you have i was uh i guess fortunate enough working in older adult settings that given that people didn't have the technology or the access and to the internet or in some um uh some settings because of the socio um economic deprivation in the area they simply didn't have internet they didn't have you know anything that
是与人面对面进行的。这确实是一门非常不同的手艺，不是吗？我显然是在学习我的手艺，就像你一样，是与人面对面进行的，这确实是一门非常不同的手艺，不是吗？即使是我们今天早上处理连接速度之类的问题，你知道，一开始试图整理你的音频，你知道，这是一个完全不同的挑战。我认为是这样，在某些方面，我无法完全远程执业，就像你那样。我当时很幸运，在老年人环境中工作，考虑到人们没有技术或无法访问互联网，或者在某些环境中，由于该地区的社会经济匮乏，他们根本没有互联网，他们没有任何东西
would provide enough um network speed to support video conversations um so we did uh a lot of our therapeutic interventions in person in people's homes during COVID, which meant we were fully gowned up with our masks and our aprons and our gloves and that in itself brings all sorts of difficulty to the therapeutic process because there's a physical barrier between you, even though you were in the room with somebody, they can't see your face. You might be wearing glasses because at that point in COVID, they were worried about transmissions through bodily fluids and your eyes. And so there was no perfect way. But I really enjoy working with people face to face. I have an option to deliver therapy in my indoor practice, my outdoor clinic and online. And I choose to do the majority of my work face to face.
能提供足够的网络速度来支持视频对话。所以我们在新冠疫情期间在人们家中进行了很多面对面的治疗干预，这意味着我们穿着全套防护服，戴着口罩、围裙和手套，这本身就给治疗过程带来了各种困难，因为你们之间存在物理屏障，即使你和某人在一起，他们也看不到你的脸。你可能戴着眼镜，因为在新冠疫情的那一刻，他们担心通过体液和眼睛传播。所以没有完美的方法。但我真的很喜欢与人面对面工作。我有选择在我的室内诊所、户外诊所和在线提供治疗的选项。而我选择大部分工作都是面对面进行的。
What you mentioned about having that human-to-human interaction is so important. But I guess in order to deepen that further and think about why we might bring the outdoors into the therapeutic process, is that there's something important about the human to other than human connection as well so what it is about being connected with nature and things outside of ourselves enables us to understand ourselves better have a deeper connection with kind of who we want to be and how we want to live in the world. And so I guess the opportunity to take therapy outdoors adds a whole new angle as well of enabling people to not only connect with you as a therapist but also for us to use nature as
你提到的那种人与人之间的互动非常重要。但我猜为了进一步深化这一点，并思考我们为什么要将户外引入治疗过程，是因为人与非人之间的联系也有重要之处。也就是说，与自然以及我们自身之外的事物建立联系，使我们能够更好地了解自己，与我们想要成为的人以及我们想要如何在世界上生活建立更深层的联系。所以我猜，将治疗带到户外的机会也增加了一个全新的角度，使人们不仅能作为治疗师与你建立联系，而且还能让我们利用自然作为
almost like a co-therapist in the process. Brilliant thank you Abby. Could you tell us a little bit about you know you said the outside therapy space or the outside therapy room could you tell us a little bit about how you set that up and what that might look like if someone was being a fly on the wall yeah so I mean I chose a place called Codbeck Reservoir to be my outdoor clinic this is a beautiful little place just on the edge of the North York Moors in the North Yorkshire area. And it's, I chose it because, well some of it was practical, it's not too far from home so my commute is not too long, but many of the reasons I chose it was because of the different terrain and landscapes that that space provided. So the reservoir is, as it says, still late. There's some lovely little kind of very evenly paved paths around it,
过程中几乎像共同治疗师一样的存在。太棒了，谢谢艾比。你能告诉我们一点关于你说的户外治疗空间或户外治疗室的情况吗？你能告诉我们一点你是如何设置它的，如果有人在旁边偷听，它看起来会是什么样子？是的，我的意思是，我选择了一个叫科德贝克水库（Codbeck Reservoir）的地方作为我的户外诊所，这是一个美丽的小地方，就在北约克郡地区北约克沼泽（North York Moors）的边缘。我选择它是因为，嗯，部分原因是实际情况，它离家不远，所以我的通勤时间不长，但我选择它的许多原因是因为那个空间提供的不同地形和景观。所以水库，正如其名，是静止的湖泊。周围有一些非常平坦的铺砌小路，
so really supports people to engage if they have more mobility issues or feel that physically they wouldn't be able to do something too strenuous. But on the banks of the reservoir, you go up into the woodland area and you can find some of those paved but kind of steeper hills, but also some beautiful little snickets, which means that you're just getting into the trees, which is just wonderful for kind of mindfulness exercises and stabilization and grounding because you've got, you know, the stimulation of all of the five senses with the bird song, all of the sunlight streaming through the trees, the different vegetation, you've got the smells of being in the woodland, you know that earthy smell or the smell after the rain, and you've got the process of walking or moving which enables kind of a deeper kinesthetic experience to touch. So there's opportunities to kind of get off the beaten track,
所以如果人们有更多的行动不便问题，或者觉得在身体上无法做太剧烈的事情，这确实支持他们参与。但在水库岸边，你向上进入林地，你可以找到一些铺砌但有点陡峭的山丘，还有一些美丽的小径，这意味着你只是进入了树林，这对于正念练习、稳定和接地非常棒，因为你有，你知道，五种感官的刺激，有鸟鸣，有穿过树木的阳光，有不同的植被，你有身处林地的气味，你知道那种泥土味或雨后的味道，而且你有行走或移动的过程，这使得一种更深层的动觉体验得以触及。所以有机会离开人迹罕至的地方，
get into the woods. And then there's also at the top of the woods, moorland, like kind of beautiful rolling moorland and kind of everlasting views across the Cleveland Hills. So there's an opportunity to literally throughout the therapy gain a different landscape or perspective as we move around. people make sense of their experiences depending on whether they're stuck in the middle of the trees in a darkened part of the wood versus at the top of the hill looking over vast expansive land so the very nature of being able to more walk through different terrains and landscapes means that people end up being able to view their experiences from very different perspectives. It sounds absolutely fascinating and yeah I do EMDR
进入树林。然后在树林顶部，还有荒原，像那种美丽的起伏荒原，以及横跨克利夫兰山（Cleveland Hills）的永恒景色。所以有机会在整个治疗过程中，随着我们的移动，获得不同的景观或视角。人们根据他们是困在树林中间黑暗的部分，还是在山顶俯瞰广阔的土地，来理解他们的经历。所以能够穿过不同地形和景观的本质意味着人们最终能够从非常不同的角度看待他们的经历。这听起来绝对令人着迷，是的，我做眼动脱敏再加工（EMDR），
and lots of work around trauma and it we're often kind of trying to find a safe space but the idea that you can in person in the moment you know create a unique safe space where you've also been with them is potentially really powerful isn't it yeah absolutely i mean we have to remember that when we're taking kind of deeply personal and emotive and sensitive therapeutic conversations into outdoor and potentially public spaces, there is going to be an impact in terms of somebody's psychological safety and confidentiality. OK, so what's really, really important in outdoor therapy is that as part of contracting and assessment and formulation, there's a deep understanding about what those individuals' experiences have
并围绕创伤做了大量工作，我们经常试图找到一个安全的空间，但你可以在当下亲自创造一个独特的安全空间，同时你也和他们在一起，这可能真的很有力量，不是吗？是的，绝对。我的意思是，我们必须记住，当我们把非常个人化、情绪化和敏感的治疗对话带到户外和潜在的公共空间时，在某人的心理安全和保密性方面会产生影响。好的，所以在户外治疗中非常非常重要的是，作为签约、评估和制定方案的一部分，要深入了解这些个人的经历
been in nature, whether there's been anything that could potentially be triggering or distressing for them, if they might find being emotive or being emotional and other people potentially passing by, if that could be a really difficult experience for them. So you've got to think creatively about how you prepare people for these situations and we'll have very individualized plans for what to do say if a member of the public comes past or if they meet somebody that they know because that's that's a possibility in these situations when taking therapy outdoors. But that's not to say that people can't make a plan that enables them to feel prepared and empowered enough to deal with that situation when it arises. And actually, on the very few situations where somebody has met somebody that they know whilst out in outdoor therapy,
在自然界中是什么样的，是否有任何可能对他们产生触发或痛苦的事情，如果他们发现情绪化或在其他人可能经过时表现出情绪，如果这对他们来说可能是一种非常困难的经历。所以你必须创造性地思考如何为这些情况做好准备，我们将有非常个性化的计划，比如如果公众经过，或者如果他们遇到认识的人该怎么办，因为在户外进行治疗时，这些情况是有可能的。但这并不是说人们不能制定一个计划，使他们感到足够准备和有能力在这种情况出现时处理它。事实上，在极少数情况下，有人在户外治疗时遇到了认识的人，
it can often offer something useful for the therapeutic process in terms of whatever is enacted or triggered by that person coming into that client safe space can then be worked through in a way that you just wouldn't get if you're sat in the four walls of the clinic room so what I think some people might see as red flags if they're carefully and effectively managed within an understandable individualized contract can actually end up meaning that there's more opportunities for learning and development than perhaps we would have by just being in therapy in a therapy room. It just sounds you know so rich and powerful and so you know full of opportunity really and what might a typical sort of first session be like for somebody well it depends on the individual really and I offer what I often call
这通常可以为治疗过程提供一些有用的东西，因为那个人进入客户安全空间所引发或触发的任何事情，都可以以一种你在诊室四壁内无法获得的方式来解决。所以，如果经过仔细和有效的管理，并在可理解的个性化合同内，我认为有些人可能视为危险信号的事情，最终可能意味着比我们在治疗室进行治疗时有更多的学习和发展机会。这听起来真是太丰富、太强大了，而且充满了机会。那么一个典型的第一次疗程会是什么样子呢？嗯，这确实取决于个人，我提供我经常称之为
a hybrid approach which is where people have the power to choose whether they want the session indoors or outdoors. I'm really fortunate that my indoor setting is a little lodge converted at the bottom of my garden and sits within a woodland canopy. So even my indoor therapy is spent, you know, within a woodland, hearing the birds song with squirrels scampering over the roof and climbing down the drain pipes outside. So there's always some sense of connection with nature, whether you're taking therapy indoors or outdoors when you're working with me. But I think it's really important at the outset
混合方法的东西，即人们有权选择他们想要室内还是室外疗程。我很幸运，我的室内环境是我花园底部的一个小木屋，坐落在林冠下。所以即使是我的室内治疗，也是在林地中度过的，听着鸟鸣，松鼠在屋顶上奔跑，爬下外面的排水管。所以当你和我一起工作时，无论你是进行室内治疗还是户外治疗，总有一种与自然的联系感。但我认为在开始时非常重要，
that people are empowered to make choices in therapy. People often come for therapy when they're feeling stuck, when they're feeling disempowered, when they feel silenced or they have no voice. And sometimes just going to sit in someone up being something that can be again silencing or pressuring or intimidating in a sense so outdoor therapy or offering a hybrid approach it gives people an opportunity to make decisions and choices about where therapy takes place, how it looks, whether we take that outdoors if they just want to sit by the reservoir, they want to take a short walk or they want to get up into the hills. They choose whether to take it outdoors or bring it indoors and that seems to serve to settle some people. So I leave that choice to them.
人们在治疗中被赋予做出选择的权力。人们在感到困顿、感到无力、感到被噤声或没有发言权时，往往会来寻求治疗。有时只是去坐在某人的对面，这本身可能再次成为一种噤声、压力或某种意义上的恐吓。所以户外治疗或提供混合方法，让人们有机会就治疗发生在哪里、看起来是什么样子做出决定和选择。如果他们只是想坐在水库边，他们想散散步，或者他们想上山，他们可以选择是带到户外还是带到室内，这似乎有助于让一些人平静下来。所以我把这个选择留给他们。
And some people will choose to have the initial assessment sessions indoors because there's something containing about developing a relationship with somebody in the four walls. process that initial raw emotion in a space that feels a little bit more private before then taking the therapy outdoors. So some people choose to do that, other people really interestingly go I couldn't bear to be in a room with my distress or actually I couldn't bear to look at you in the face that's really intimidating and i just want to meet outdoors so i give them a choice and they can make those decisions if it's an outdoor therapy session what's really important is that we build in a sense of therapeutic frame and boundaries so that that also offers some sense of psychological safety to the individual but also to the practitioner so I have what I call a therapy threshold which is a place where we start and end therapy no matter what when we're outdoors it marks in some ways
有些人会选择在室内进行初步评估疗程，因为在四壁内与某人建立关系有一种包含感。在感觉更私密的空间中处理最初的原始情绪，然后再将治疗带到户外。所以有些人选择这样做，其他人非常有趣地说，我无法忍受在房间里面对我的痛苦，或者实际上我无法忍受看着你的脸，那太吓人了，我只想在户外见面。所以我给他们一个选择，他们可以做出这些决定。如果是户外治疗疗程，非常重要的是我们建立一种治疗框架和界限，这样这也为个人以及从业者提供某种心理安全感。所以我有一个我称之为治疗阈值的东西，无论我们在户外做什么，这是我们开始和结束治疗的地方。它在某种程度上标志着
that that idea of walking through the door of the therapy room. This is when therapy starts and it's when therapy ends. And it's my responsibility to get people back there within the hour, which can be challenging at times. But largely within the therapy, I give them the choice on where they go. So we meet a fork in the path, and they're choosing where they like the session to go. And this is what Cooley and the Wells suggested in the guidance offers an enhancement and an enrichment to a therapy that they call mutuality. So there's a mutuality that's developed within the therapeutic relationship, which means that that power imbalance has been broken down. It's less hierarchical.
那种走进治疗室门的想法。这是治疗开始的时候，也是治疗结束的时候。我有责任在一小时内把人们带回那里，这有时可能具有挑战性。但在治疗过程中，我很大程度上让他们选择去哪里。所以我们在小路的岔路口相遇，他们选择他们想要疗程去的地方。这就是库利和威尔斯在指南中建议的，为他们称之为“互惠性”（mutuality）的治疗提供了一种增强和丰富。因此，在治疗关系中发展出一种互惠性，这意味着权力不平衡已经被打破。它不再那么等级森严。
They're no longer stepping into my space. I'm stepping with them into theirs or into our space. Nature isn't owned necessarily by anybody. Yes, we might have landowners, but it's a space for us all to embrace and we all have our own connection and story with being outdoors. So taking therapy outdoors means that it's no longer on my terms. It offers the opportunity for that client to feel comfortable in a space what's the word it's just calming in some way
他们不再走进我的空间。我正与他们一起走进他们的空间，或者走进我们的空间。自然不一定属于任何人。是的，我们可能有土地所有者，但这是一个让我们所有人拥抱的空间，我们每个人在户外都有自己的联系和故事。所以把治疗带到户外意味着它不再是按我的条件进行的。它为客户提供了一个机会，让他们在空间中感到舒适，怎么说呢，它在某种程度上只是让人平静。
you might be able to relate to this Marianne you know often people say well you know if I want to put the world to rights I'll go and have a walk with my friend and we'll talk about everything. And we can do that because there's no interpersonal pressure. We're not being scared out. We're not being watched. And being in nature, it's distracting in terms of the stimuli that's around us, but it's also calming and restorative. So we can have really deep and personal, intimate conversations in a way that feels less intimidating than if we were just in the house or trying to have a conversation over dinner.
你可能能体会到这一点，玛丽安，你知道，人们常说，嗯，如果我想理清思绪，我会去和朋友散步，我们会谈论一切。我们可以这样做，因为没有这种人际压力。我们没有被盯着看。我们没有被监视。身处自然中，就我们周围的刺激而言，它是分散注意力的，但它也是平静和恢复性的。所以我们可以进行非常深入、个人化、亲密的对话，感觉比我们只是在家里或试图在晚餐时交谈时压力要小。
So that mutuality and that sense of freedom that comes with working alongside somebody and kind of entering into their own world really frees up the therapeutic alliance and enables people to be much more expressive probably earlier on in the therapy yeah and i don't know if you're aware of it but um the founder of um EMDR who sadly passed away quite recently she put that together as a model initially because she'd been out for a walk and thinking about something that had been really problematic for her and observed that the very act of walking you know I think she was tapping her legs as she went sort of absent-mindedly she felt a lot better and so you know even talking think she was tapping her legs as she went sort of absentmindedly, she felt a lot better
所以那种互惠性和与某人并肩工作并进入他们自己的世界所带来的自由感，确实释放了治疗联盟，并使人们在治疗初期就能更加表达自己。是的，我不知道你是否知道，但眼动脱敏再加工（EMDR）的创始人，不幸的是最近去世了，她最初把这个模型放在一起，因为她出去散步，思考着对她来说非常成问题的事情，并观察到行走的动作，你知道，我想她在走的时候心不在焉地拍打着她的腿，她感觉好多了。所以，你知道，即使谈论
and so, you know, even talking about things that are challenging as somebody is walking or using both hands, for example, you're getting that bilateral stimulation which helps everything process and lay flatter, doesn't it? Absolutely, absolutely and so bilateral stimulation is the core part of what taking therapy outdoors brings to the process, because walking, as you say, one foot in front of the other provides that bilateral stimulation of the brain, which we need in order to process traumatic experience and memories. So you don't really need to test or do any of that because walking itself will offer the same stimulation that's required. But kind of to deepen that a little bit more, we can take, we can think about the cat plan and cat plan theory about attention restoration. So in our day-to-day lives, you know, when we're working, when we're
那些具有挑战性的事情，当某人行走或使用双手时，例如，你得到了那种双侧刺激，这有助于一切处理并变得平稳，不是吗？绝对，绝对。所以双侧刺激是户外治疗带给过程的核心部分，因为行走，正如你所说，一只脚在另一只脚前面，提供了大脑所需的双侧刺激，我们需要它来处理创伤经历和记忆。所以你真的不需要测试或做任何这些，因为行走本身就会提供所需的相同刺激。但为了稍微深化这一点，我们可以考虑卡普兰（Kaplan）和卡普兰关于注意力恢复的理论。在我们的日常生活中，你知道，当我们工作时，当我们
on the computer, when we're studying, you know, we're on placements and we're actively trying to problem solve, decision make, you know, consider rationales for things um we're using a part of the attentional system called focused attention okay and when we're using that day in day out it's extremely fatiguing it's resource heavy um and that's why at the end of the day when we've kind of you know finish the day at work or we've been working on an assignment um or we've been um you know spending endless kind of hours looking at the computer doing zoom stuff it's it's kind of just um mind-numbing you might end up with a bit of fog might might have a headache, we might have reduced attention, our concentration might not be quite as good. What nature offers us is an opportunity to switch systems. So in nature, we tend to utilize part of the attentionalal system which is unfocused or spontaneous because we're
在电脑上时，当我们学习时，你知道，我们在实习，我们正在积极尝试解决问题、做决定、你知道，考虑事情的理由，我们正在使用注意力系统的一部分，称为“聚焦注意力”（focused attention）。好的，当我们日复一日地使用它时，它非常令人疲劳，资源密集，这就是为什么在一天结束时，当我们完成了工作，或者我们一直在做作业，或者我们一直在花无数时间盯着电脑做Zoom的事情时，它只是让人麻木。我们可能会有点脑雾，可能会头痛，我们的注意力可能会降低，我们的专注力可能不会那么好。自然为我们提供了一个切换系统的机会。所以在自然界中，我们倾向于利用注意力系统中非聚焦或自发的部分，因为我们
constantly just drawn to something visual in our in our visual fields or in our auditory fields or what we're feeling with the wind kind of brushing through our our skin we'll suddenly turn to that that place or away from it we'll see something we like we'll hear something we like and we're no longer engaging in focused attention we are using spontaneous attention and we're just drawn to whatever is around us so that automatically means that our eyes are moving left and right left and right left and right that bilateral stimulation happens no matter what um and um cat plan and cat plan suggested with attentional restoration theory that moving on to kind of that unfocused attentional system enables um uh the kind of a
不断地被我们视野中或听觉领域中的视觉事物所吸引，或者我们用风拂过皮肤的感觉所吸引，我们会突然转向那个地方或远离它，我们会看到我们喜欢的东西，我们会听到我们喜欢的东西，我们不再参与聚焦注意力，我们正在使用自发注意力，我们只是被周围的任何东西所吸引。所以这意味着我们的眼睛自动地左右移动，左右移动，左右移动，那种双侧刺激无论如何都会发生。而且，卡普兰和卡普兰在注意力恢复理论中建议，转向那种非聚焦的注意力系统，使得
restoration of concentrated or focused attention. So it actually ends up being something that's important for our cognitive restoration and supports kind of in terms of rest and managing fatigue. So just to kind of take that idea a little bit further, not just only is it about the walking and the movement of our body left and right, but our eyes are drawn and our senses are drawn in different directions. And that also offers another level of the bilateral stimulation of the brain. So useful. So interesting as well. Thanks for sharing that with us um i guess i'm thinking
集中或聚焦的注意力得以恢复。所以它最终成为对我们的认知恢复很重要的事情，并支持休息和管理疲劳。所以为了把这个想法再推进一步，不仅是关于行走和我们身体左右的移动，而且我们的眼睛被吸引，我们的感官被吸引到不同的方向。这也提供了大脑双侧刺激的另一个层面。太有用了。也太有趣了。谢谢你与我们分享这些。嗯，我猜我在想
about our audience being aspiring psychologists um and or mental health professionals um and i'm imagining you know in fact i did suggest going out and walking with clients and it was very family said no it's too risky um how do you begin to kind of have that conversation with employing trusts, managers, supervisors, teams around risk, Gabby? Well, I think it can be a little bit more difficult. But as long as you've got multiple levels of assessment of risk throughout your contracting and formulation, and you can make a clear articulated argument for why taking therapy might be in this person's best interest, then you should have a strong case. You can use the Cooley and Noel guidance to really help you to understand what needs to be considered as potential risks within outdoor therapy
关于我们的听众是立志成为心理学家和/或心理健康专业人士，我正在想象，事实上，我确实建议过出去和客户一起散步，但很多人说不，这太冒险了。艾比，你如何开始与雇佣信托、经理、主管、团队就风险进行那种对话？嗯，我认为这可能会稍微困难一些。但只要你在签约和制定方案的过程中有多个层面的风险评估，并且你能为为什么进行治疗可能符合这个人的最大利益提出清晰的论点，那么你应该有一个强有力的理由。你可以使用库利和诺埃尔的指南来真正帮助你理解在户外治疗中需要考虑哪些潜在风险，
and what might be required to mitigate against those. So, for example, in the assessment process, you would have questions about what that person's relationship is with nature, why they're drawn to taking therapy outdoors. Some people just have a natural affiliation with being outdoors. That's where they go to heal and to be invigorated. I know that's certainly the case for me. And that's a little bit about my journey into why I chose to become a specialist in outdoor therapy,
以及可能需要采取什么措施来减轻这些风险。例如，在评估过程中，你会询问那个人与自然的关系，为什么他们被吸引到户外进行治疗。有些人只是对户外有一种自然的亲和力。那是他们去治愈和恢复活力的地方。我知道我肯定就是这样。这与我为什么选择成为户外治疗专家的旅程有关，
which I can share in a little while if you're interested. But you want to find out what the relationship that person has with the outdoors is, why they might want to deepen it. Now, some ecopsychologists suggest that actually, the research that we're looking at is the wrong way around. It's not that there's physical and psychological benefits to being in nature. It's actually the fact that due to industrialization and urbanization, humans have been removed from their natural communal settings.
我稍后可以分享，如果你感兴趣的话。但你想找出那个人与户外的关系是什么，为什么他们可能想加深它。现在，一些生态心理学家建议，实际上，我们正在研究的研究方向是错误的。并不是说身处自然中对身心有益，实际上是因为工业化和城市化，人类已经从自然的公共环境中被剥离出来。
And it is that disconnection with nature which is causing us distress and I think that's really powerful to the point where some people will suggest that there is a thing called nature deficit disorder that the reason we're hurting as humans is because we're no longer living connected with nature. We forget that as human beings, we are nature. We are an animal and an organism in this greater whole. But unfortunately, I guess the way that humans have developed in modern societies and modern cultures is that we often think ourselves as greater than nature and the things around us and that that has led to some
正是这种与自然的脱节导致了我们的痛苦，我认为这非常有力量，以至于有些人会建议有一种东西叫“自然缺失症”（nature deficit disorder），即我们人类之所以受伤，是因为我们不再与自然和谐相处。我们忘记了作为人类，我们就是自然。我们是这个大整体中的一种动物和有机体。但不幸的是，我猜人类在现代社会和现代文化中的发展方式是，我们经常认为自己比自然和周围的事物更伟大，而这导致了一些
difficult situations like the climate crisis that we find ourselves in. But yeah so there's this sense that if we enable people to connect more with the natural world, not only will they gain the benefit of kind of, you know, reduced stress, reduced anxiety, lifted moods, sense of contentment, the physical benefits of being in nature are kind of linked to the reducing, kind of the suppressing of the stress response and supporting our immune system, supporting our cardiovascular system, those types of things. If we actually enable people to connect more with nature, they're going to reap the benefits of that. And I guess that's one of the reasons why I was interested in bringing therapy outdoors and making people more connected
困难的情况，比如我们发现自己所处的气候危机。但是，是的，有一种感觉是，如果我们使人们能够更多地与自然世界建立联系，他们不仅会获得减轻压力、减轻焦虑、改善情绪、获得满足感的益处，身处自然中的身体益处也与抑制压力反应和支持我们的免疫系统、支持我们的心血管系统等有关。如果我们真的使人们能够更多地与自然建立联系，他们将从中受益。我猜这就是我为什么对将治疗带到户外并使人们更多地与他们的自然土地建立联系感兴趣的原因之一。是的，我想在
with their natural land. Yeah, and I think in
但并非所有治疗师都在这样做，因为他们无法获得房间，而引入一个新的治疗性户外空间在应对这种困难方面非常有用。是的，完全正确。我认为是的，组织可能会因为拓宽他们对治疗可以在哪里进行的视角而受益，这有逻辑上的原因。但我也认为，认识到对客户治疗结果的影响是很重要的。像你这样的客户，我相信玛丽安，会花很多时间，很多疗程在房间里和一个客户在一起，感觉真的非常困难，感觉就像，我脑海中浮现的短语是，就像从石头里挤血一样。在某些环境中的人们，他们封闭自己，他们努力去感受足够的安全来表达自己，特别是那些经历过某种程度忽视或虐待的人，
but not all therapists were doing that because they couldn't get the rooms and potentially introducing a new therapeutic outdoor space is quite useful in combating that difficulty yeah exactly I think so there's going to be logistical reasons why organizations might benefit from broadening their perspective on where therapy can be delivered. But also, I think there's something important about recognizing the impact on therapeutic outcomes for clients. clients like you I'm sure Marianne will have spent many a time many a session um in a room with a client and it's felt really really difficult it's felt like kind of the the phrase that's coming to my mind is like it's like drawing blood from the stone like people in some settings they they they close up they struggle struggle to feel safe enough to express themselves, particularly those people who have experienced some level of neglect or abuse,
发现很难信任他人。对一些人来说，和某人待在一个房间里是瘫痪的。这剥夺了他们的声音，他们感到沉默。对于这些人，实际上我们从和某人待在一个房间里获得的治疗结果是有限的。所以当时我和一些人一起工作，在离开NHS之前，我为他们提出了一个商业案例，将治疗讨论带到外面。谢天谢地，我当时有一位非常有创造力的首席心理学家，他为我授权了这一点。这改变了工作。你把那个人放在一个他们感到安全的设置中，因为那是他们的，他们对它有所有权，而且你没有盯着他们的脸。你正与他们并肩行走，突然他们就能说话了。
find it difficult to trust others. For some people, being in a room with somebody is paralyzing. It removes their voice, they feel silent. For those people, actually the therapeutic outcomes that we can get from being in a room with someone is limited. So there were some people that I was working with at the time, prior to leaving the NHS, and I put a business case forward for them to take that therapy discussion outside. And thankfully, I had quite a creative lead psychologist at the time who authorised that for me. And it just transforms the work. You put that person in a setting which they feel safe in because it's theirs, they have ownership over it, and you're not staring them in the face. You're walking alongside them and suddenly they can speak.
对于那些个人来说，治疗结果，益处将显著更好。所以组织将从人们获得最适合他们个人需求的治疗中受益，这意味着我们将以满足每个人不同需求的方式处理那些等待名单。现在，并不是每个人都想进行户外治疗，也不是每个从业者都想这样做。非常重要的是要认识到，在将工作带到户外方面必须有共同的兴趣。
And for those individuals, the therapeutic outcome, the benefit is going to be significantly better. So organizations are going to benefit from people having access to a therapy which is best suited to their individual needs, which means that they're going to be, we're going to be working through those wait lists in a way that meets everybody's differing needs. Now, not everybody wants to take therapy outdoors and not every practitioner wants to do that either. What's really important is recognising that there has to be a joint interest in taking that work outdoors.
因为如果我们最终试图强迫一些从业者做他们不舒服的事情，我们实际上会损害治疗过程。如果我们因为没有房间而试图把每个人都放在户外治疗中，而他们对户外没有自然的亲和力，或者也许在户外发生了创伤性或触发性的事情，
Because if we end up trying to force some practitioners to do something they're not comfortable with, we're actually gonna damage the therapeutic process. And if we try and put everybody in outdoor therapy because we don't have rooms, when they don't have a natural affiliation with the outdoors, or maybe something traumatic or triggering happens for them outdoors,
我们将对人们造成伤害。所以这不仅仅是关于这是我们应该提供的东西，它回到了那个非常定制的初步评估和制定方案，关于自然和户外对这个特定个人来说什么是治疗性的、令人振奋的或恢复性的，以及这如何与他们更通用和传统的治疗目标相结合，并将这些事情结合在一起。绝对。所以听起来它不仅为客户定制，也为治疗师定制。嗯，是的，我能想象到我合作过的许多客户，他们曾在林地里被侵犯，或者出去跑步，你知道，那不是，那只会是洪水猛兽，不是吗？
we're gonna be doing people harm so it's not just about this is something we should just be offering it's coming back down to that very bespoke initial assessment and formulation about what is it about nature and being outdoors it's therapeutic or invigorating or restorative for this particular individual and how does that marry alongside their more generic and traditional therapeutic goals and bringing those things together absolutely so it sounds like it's bespoke for the client but also for the therapist as well um and yeah i'm imagining a number of clients i've worked with who've been you know salted in woodlands or went out running you know that's not that would just be flooding wouldn't it do
我们可能会伤害到他人，所以这不仅仅是我们应该提供的东西，而是要回归到最初那种非常定制化的评估和构思，即对于这个特定的个体来说，大自然和户外活动中究竟是什么让他们感到治愈、振奋或恢复活力，以及这如何与他们更通用和传统的治疗目标相结合。确实如此，所以听起来这不仅是为客户量身定制的，也是为治疗师量身定制的。嗯，是的，我想到了我曾合作过的许多客户，他们可能被带到林地里或者去跑步，那根本行不通，那只会造成心理冲击，不是吗？
that to them straight off the bat exactly and some people don't realize so i've had people come exploring and interested in outdoor therapy and they've not made connections with their their experience which actually could end up being quite triggering or challenging for that person and that's not to say that we then don't do it we might do it in a more graded way and we might have very explicit things around particular parts of nature or interactions which would be more challenging and have ways of managing or mitigating against those becoming potentially triggering situations. So it's not a blanket rule and it's not one size fits all. It's very individualized and it can change. So I've had people who I've been working with indoors and we felt stuck to a point you know we've done some good work but
直接向他们说明这一点，有些人并没有意识到。我曾遇到过一些人，他们对户外治疗很感兴趣，但并没有将这种治疗与他们自身的经历联系起来，而这些经历实际上可能会引发他们的负面情绪或带来挑战。这并不是说我们就不做了，我们可能会以一种更循序渐进的方式进行，并对自然环境中的特定部分或互动方式进行明确的界定，这些部分可能更具挑战性，我们会采取一些方法来管理或减轻这些可能引发负面情绪的情况。所以，这并不是一条一刀切的规则，也不是千篇一律的。它是非常个性化的，而且是可以改变的。我曾与一些人在室内工作，我们感到陷入了僵局，你知道，我们虽然做了一些不错的工作，但
it's just not moved on um a particular client's coming to mind um I was working with him in relation to an abusive relationship that he was stuck in um but he hadn't realized it was abusive to start off with and had some really challenging suicidal ideation and intent around what he was struggling with at the time, although he didn't realise the reasons why he was feeling that way. We did a good piece of work using Kat to help make sense of the relational dynamics he was struggling with. And he knew he had to leave. But we kept getting snagged, you know, make really, really clear plans about how he can do that
进展却停滞不前。我想到了一位特定的来访者，我曾就他陷入的一段虐待关系与他进行过咨询。但他起初并没有意识到那是虐待，并且在当时他所挣扎的事情上，产生了一些非常严重的自杀意念和企图，尽管他并没有意识到自己为什么会有这种感觉。我们利用KAT（认知分析治疗）进行了一次很好的工作，帮助他理清了他在关系动力学中挣扎的原因。他知道自己必须离开，但我们总是遇到阻碍，你知道，即使制定了非常非常明确的离开计划，
safely. And he would get caught and pulled back in again. So I offered that therapy to take to go outdoors, sometimes putting one foot in front of the other literally means moving, becoming unstuck. And for him, it was the landscapes that really offered something very beneficial for the therapeutic intervention. So he was drawn to going up, you know, onto the hillside. And I asked him what he was feeling as he up onto the hillside. And I asked him what he was feeling as he got to the top when he was looking out over the expansive kind of landscape. And he just said, free.
确保安全，他还是会被困住并再次被拉回去。所以我提议将治疗带到户外，有时字面意义上的迈出一步意味着开始移动，摆脱困境。对他来说，正是这些景观为治疗干预提供了非常有益的东西。他被吸引去往山上，我问他在登上山坡时有什么感觉。当我问他在到达山顶，俯瞰广阔的景观时有什么感觉，他只是说，自由。
This is freedom. This is what I want. This is what I need. And it was almost, it was a very powerful embodied emotional experience of what freedom felt like, that he didn't have any grasp of that before then. There was this sense of an emotional embodied experience that, oh, this is what I'm after. And versus seeing, which was a space just on the other
这就是自由。这就是我想要的。这就是我所需要的。这几乎是一种非常强大的、具身化的情感体验，让他感受到了自由是什么样的，在那之前他对此毫无概念。这是一种情感上的具身化体验，让他意识到，哦，这就是我所追求的。与此相对的是，在干石墙的另一边，
side of a dry stone wall of deforestation of kind of like a burial ground for trees and we went there and he was like oh god this is where I am this is where I'm stuck now it's like a graveyard I'm trapped um and we did some work about what what he needed to do to be able to either climb over the wall or walk through the gate and it was really powerful stuff um and the next session he'd left and I was like why did you leave and he was like oh because I knew what that felt like now I knew that that was worth it and it didn't matter how frightening it was the potential of leaving I knew I knew what hope felt like I knew what it looked like and I could climb over the wall
是一片森林砍伐后的景象，就像树木的墓地。我们去了那里，他说，天哪，这就是我现在的处境，我被困在这里了，就像一个坟墓，我被困住了。我们做了一些工作，探讨他需要做什么才能翻过那堵墙或穿过大门，这非常有力量。在下一次咨询时，他已经离开了。我问他为什么离开，他说，因为我现在知道那种感觉是什么样的了，我知道那是值得的。无论离开的过程有多么可怕，我知道希望是什么感觉，我知道它看起来是什么样，我可以翻过那堵墙。
so powerful and such transformative stuff isn't it you know and yeah it's you never know what's going to be the difference that makes the difference until it's happened until it's done it's honestly we've just got the best job in the world to be part it's a real privilege isn't it to be part of people's stories and part of people's transformation and healing just before we finish I'm conscious of time and I would like to talk to you all day but um this career of ours can be really tricky to get into and especially around this time of year with interviews and you know people having other people's celebration their own celebrations or their own disappointments and that kind of relentless slog of autumn's coming I've got to
太有力量了，真是太具变革性了，不是吗？你永远不知道什么会成为带来改变的关键，直到它发生，直到它完成。老实说，我们拥有世界上最好的工作，能够参与其中，成为人们故事的一部分，成为人们转变和治愈的一部分，这真是一种荣幸。在结束之前，我意识到时间紧迫，虽然我想和你聊一整天，但我们这个职业入门确实非常棘手，特别是在每年的这个时候，面试很多，人们还要应对别人的庆祝活动、自己的庆祝活动或失望，还有那种秋天即将来临的无情苦差事，我必须
all again and you know I've got to do research I've got to do you know clinical work I've got to formulate I've got to reflect there's a lot um have you something I ask lots of my guests, have you got like a top tip to try and reduce burnout in people's lives, Abby? So I didn't live in Teesside or even know where Teesside was before I kind of applied to the course. And I applied to a variety of different universities in Stoke North because I'm a northern girl at heart. And when I came over here, you know, I did certain things for myself, good friendship groups I had, I did a bit of running that I enjoyed, but I was moving away from all my family and friends, let's face it, it was a really difficult time, I'd never lived in Teesside before, I didn't know anyone here, and so that was really challenging. But that's where my love for nature came in. I was, you know, I switched my road shoes for some trail shoes and I found a local running
重新开始。我必须做研究，我必须做临床工作，我必须进行案例构思，我必须进行反思，事情真的很多。我问过很多嘉宾一个问题，Abby，你有没有什么绝招可以减轻生活中的职业倦怠？我搬到蒂赛德之前，甚至不知道蒂赛德在哪里。我申请了斯托克北部不同的大学，因为我内心是个北方女孩。当我来到这里时，我为自己做了一些事情，比如建立良好的朋友圈，我喜欢跑步，但我远离了所有的家人和朋友，说实话，那是一段非常艰难的时光。我以前从未在蒂赛德住过，这里一个人也不认识，所以那真的很有挑战性。但这就是我对大自然的热爱发挥作用的地方。我换上了越野跑鞋，找到了一个当地的跑步
group and I used them to help me to explore the local area. I downloaded OSMAP's app on my phone and I just immersed myself in nature. And I genuinely think that that was something that was hugely important in enabling me to feel a sense of balance when I was undertaking the doctorate program. there is so much pressure okay whether you're doing all of the work and all of the voluntary stuff and trying to get everything in your application or whether you're already on training and trying to figure out how to balance all of the different parts of the job that it's so important to hold on to something restorative for you. Restoration and working in a way that helps me to be invigorated and calmed was the reason I took therapy outdoors. That is the benefit that it has for me. So I guess make space for time in nature.
小组，并利用他们来帮助我探索当地。我在手机上下载了OSMAP应用程序，让自己沉浸在大自然中。我真心认为，这对于我在攻读博士学位期间保持平衡感至关重要。压力太大了，无论你是要完成所有的工作、所有的志愿服务，还是试图在申请中涵盖一切，或者你已经在接受培训，试图弄清楚如何平衡工作的各个部分，保持一些能让你恢复活力的东西是非常重要的。恢复活力以及以一种能让我振奋和冷静的方式工作，是我将治疗带到户外的初衷。这就是它带给我的益处。所以，我想说，在自然中留出时间吧。
It is deeply therapeutic it doesn't need to be massive our connection with the outdoors and getting um benefit doesn't need to be you know going hiking in the lake district it doesn't need to be far away it can be as as simple simple as taking an early morning walk in can rest appropriately and manage all of the stress and the burnout that we might be experiencing throughout the day. So I guess a couple of things jump to mind. I really like the idea of a sit spot. So you could take five minutes and go and sit in a natural space, be that a park, a garden, a cemetery, by the beach. It doesn't need to be wondrous and awe-inspiring. And sit down, close your eyes,
这具有深刻的治疗作用，不需要非常隆重。我们与户外的联系以及从中获得的益处，并不一定非要去湖区徒步旅行，也不需要去很远的地方。它可以简单到只是在清晨散散步，就能适当地休息并管理我们在一天中可能经历的所有压力和倦怠。所以，我想到了几点。我非常喜欢“静坐点”这个想法。你可以花五分钟去一个自然空间坐坐，无论是公园、花园、墓地还是海边。它不需要多么奇妙或令人敬畏。坐下来，闭上眼睛，
tune in with your senses, what you can hear, what what you can feel perhaps the wind around you and slowly open your eyes look around you in your immediate vicinity look at the floor the grass beneath you perhaps even better have taken off your shoes and feel the grass underneath your toes and take in all that you can through your five senses and your immediate surrounding and then through that five minutes gently unfold a little bit further and look a little bit further into the distance until suddenly at the end of the exercise you've got your whole kind of experience you can turn around and take in the 360 degrees and just notice what it feels
调动你的感官，听听你能听到什么，感受一下周围的风，然后慢慢睁开眼睛，看看你周围的近处，看看地面，看看脚下的草地，甚至更好的是，脱掉鞋子，感受脚趾下的草地，通过你的五种感官和周围的环境去感受一切。然后在那五分钟里，轻轻地向外延伸，看向更远的地方，直到练习结束时，你已经拥有了完整的体验，你可以转过身，感受360度的全景，只需注意那种感觉。
like to be deeply connected through your five senses in a space in the in the natural world in your environment um and just take a pause for you take a pause in nature and connect and another thing that i really find valuable and it kind of links into the case example that I just shared, is that we can often find ourselves stuck or perplexed or with a question. We just feel indecisive and we can't find the right answer. Getting a different perspective is really, really valuable. There's times in that scenario where we see we can't see the wood for the trees, we're just stuck in the problem and we can't see a way out. So take that problem on a walk with you. You know, you might walk, if you can get up high, really great because there's a sense of helicoptering up when we get high.
通过五种感官与自然世界和环境深度连接是什么感觉。在自然中暂停一下，建立连接。我发现非常有价值的另一件事，它与我刚才分享的案例有关，那就是我们经常会发现自己陷入困境、感到困惑或面临问题。我们只是感到优柔寡断，找不到正确的答案。获得不同的视角是非常非常有价值的。在那种情况下，有时我们“不识庐山真面目，只缘身在此山中”，我们只是被困在问题里，找不到出路。所以，带着那个问题去散步吧。如果你能登高，那就太棒了，因为当我们登高时，有一种直升机般的俯瞰感。
We see things from a completely different perspective. We're enabled to think more reflexively about our situations when we have height. height or if we can't find height just gently allow that question to form as we take a walk through a wood or in nature in general and see what happens see what answer and what answers the natural environment can provide thank you that's the most wonderful um answer and i know it's one that people will find really useful it's not like a massive thing that you need to do everyone can find those five minutes and I've actually got we've got Easter break coming up as we talk today and I've got some time booked in in a woodland with my children so that makes me feel even more you know like that's the right activity to do so thank you for nourishing me in that way but an've had an absolute joy talking to you
我们从一个完全不同的角度看待事物。当我们有高度时，我们能够更反思性地思考我们的处境。或者，如果我们找不到高处，那就让我们在穿过树林或在自然中散步时，轻轻地让那个问题形成，看看会发生什么，看看自然环境能提供什么答案。谢谢你，这是最美妙的回答，我知道人们会觉得它非常有用。这并不是什么需要大费周章的事情，每个人都能找到那五分钟。我们谈话的今天正好临近复活节假期，我已经预留了一些时间和孩子们在林地里度过，这让我觉得这确实是正确的活动，所以谢谢你以这种方式滋养了我。和你聊天真是太愉快了，
today Abby. If people want to know more about you and your work where's the best place for them to follow and connect? Yeah so you can follow me on LinkedIn if you just look for Dr Abby Karen Jones I'm sure that you're going to put everything in the bio Marianne but also if you want to go to my website that's www.theoutdoorpsychologist.co.uk and then on Instagram I am the underscore underscore outdoor underscore psychologist so you can look for me in a variety of different places and if you're interested to learn more about what I do reach out connect I'd be curious to hear your questions or to hear your reflections on what you've heard today. Thank you so much, Abby. I'm sure you'll be, yeah, you'll be very popular.
Abby。如果人们想了解更多关于你和你的工作的信息，最好的关注和联系方式是什么？是的，你可以在LinkedIn上关注我，搜索Dr Abby Karen Jones，我相信你会把所有信息都放在简介里，Marianne。此外，如果你想访问我的网站，网址是www.theoutdoorpsychologist.co.uk，在Instagram上，我是the__outdoor__psychologist，所以你可以在很多不同的地方找到我。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于我的工作，请联系我，我很期待听到你的问题或你对今天所听内容的感想。非常感谢你，Abby。我相信你会非常受欢迎的。
People will be tapping up your little inbox. So thank you very much. It's honestly been really, really interesting and yeah, really nourishing speaking to you. And I'm going to definitely think about how I can enrich my own life with more outdoors stuff, but also my children as well who are still quite young as well so yes thank you so much. Yeah you're welcome Marielle
人们会涌向你的收件箱的。所以非常感谢你。老实说，这真的非常非常有趣，和你交谈真的很滋养。我一定会考虑如何用更多的户外活动来丰富我自己的生活，还有我的孩子们，他们也还很小，所以是的，非常感谢。不客气，Marielle。
and thank you for inviting me today it's been lovely to speak to you. Thank you so much to our guest Dr Abby Tarran-Jones. I hope you found that as interesting as I did. And it certainly made me think about how we use our bodies, how we use our voices, where we deliver therapy, and the value of the setting in which we deliver it. Let me know any salient learning points for you. Also, let me know what's happened if you've tried to take therapy outside of traditional therapy walls in your trust or wherever you work and how you got on. Love to know what you make of all this in the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community, brackets, free group with Dr. Marianne Trent. So do come on over there. Please do come and connect with me on my socials as well. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. And
也谢谢你今天邀请我，和你交谈非常愉快。非常感谢我们的嘉宾Dr Abby Tarran-Jones。希望你觉得这和我一样有趣。它确实让我思考我们如何使用身体、如何使用声音、我们在哪里进行治疗，以及我们进行治疗的环境的价值。请让我知道对你来说有哪些突出的学习点。此外，如果你尝试过在你的信托机构或工作场所的传统治疗室之外进行治疗，请告诉我发生了什么，以及进展如何。我很想在免费的Facebook群组“Aspiring Psychologist Community”（由Dr. Marianne Trent管理的免费群组）中了解你的想法。所以一定要来那里。也请在社交媒体上与我联系。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。而且
if you're watching on YouTube, even if you're not watching on YouTube, slip on over, type in Dr. Marianne Trent, click subscribe and like a few things as well. If you're feeling particularly generous, please fling some comments into some of the videos as well. I realized that I've done it again. I realized that I had it in the diary to do a compassionate Q&A on Monday, the 17th of April. But that's also the same time that I have an expert in the membership, guiding people through CBT formulation and skills. And it was all about how to do that well and how to think about planning your intervention and talking about your intervention, which can be really useful for interviews as well. And that was on my mind and in my diary for 7.30, but I'd neglected to
如果你在YouTube上观看，即使你不在YouTube上观看，也请过来，输入Dr. Marianne Trent，点击订阅并点赞一些视频。如果你特别慷慨，也请在一些视频下发表评论。我意识到我又做了一次。我意识到我在日记里安排了在4月17日星期一进行一次富有同情心的问答。但那也是我在会员群里有专家指导人们进行CBT构思和技能培训的时间。这完全是关于如何做好这一点，以及如何考虑规划你的干预措施并谈论你的干预措施，这对面试也非常有用。这在我的脑海里，也在我的日记里，定在7点半，但我忽略了
see that I was also supposed to be running a free Compassionate Q&A. So I'm so sorry. I am likely to schedule it for a Tuesday because I think I need to keep Mondays free because Mondays are the days where we have Marianne Mondays in the membership. And clearly, it's too much for me to hold in mind that I've got two things happening at 7.30 on a Monday so it is likely to take place on Tuesday the 25th of April at 6pm so I'm going to get that in the diary and I really hope you can join me and I'm once again very sorry for anybody that was hoping to catch up with me last Monday. I totally forgot. To err is human.
看到我那天还应该进行一次免费的富有同情心的问答。所以我很抱歉。我可能会把它改到星期二，因为我觉得我需要保持星期一的空闲，因为星期一是我们会员群里“Marianne Mondays”的日子。显然，要我记住星期一晚上7点半有两件事发生对我来说太多了，所以它很可能会在4月25日星期二下午6点举行。我会把它记在日记里，我真的希望你能加入我。对于那些希望在上周一赶上我的人，我再次表示非常抱歉。我完全忘记了。人非圣贤，孰能无过。
And again, I'm sorry. And if you needed that for your interviews, I can only apologize. As you might well know, we have new episodes of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast landing at 6 a.m. each Monday morning. And so have a lovely week, be kind to yourself, and I'll look forward to catching up with you for our next episode. Thanks for being part of my world. Take care. Professionals on their way to getting qualified. So many tips and lessons to learn from. So many things that you can try.
再次表示歉意。如果你在面试中需要这些，我只能道歉。正如你可能知道的那样，Aspiring Psychologist播客的新剧集在每周一早上6点发布。所以祝你度过愉快的一周，善待自己，我期待在下一集与你相见。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。正在成为合格专业人士的路上。有很多技巧和经验可以学习。有很多事情你可以尝试。
The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective with this podcast I feel sad you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a
Aspiring Psychologist Collective。Aspiring Psychologist Collective，有了这个播客，我觉得很伤心，你将走上成为合格专业人士的道路，这是Dr Marianne Trent的Aspiring Psychologist播客。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《Clinical Psychologist Collective》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，这让我感到惊讶，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得自己做错了，也减轻了自己的压力。所以如果你对成为一名
clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。